when i watched the last episode i was
just like
wow
yeah it blew me away felt honest i
haven't actually seen it yet you've seen
more than i have but i might think i've
been in it
[Laughter]
i have watched it and i i was blown away
i lived it i loved that scene
you wish to invade the dreaming if you
command it
and then perhaps the waking world
[Music]
and
one day
even the silver city i love that scene
because neil and alan
really um that was something that was
just dating for some time
and um i felt like i was unleashed i was
unleashed there
it's exciting isn't it i also want to
set the scene
for season two because in season two
the lucifer
morpheus rematch is going to happen and
it is going to be stranger
darker and much more disrupted to
morpheus
than anybody
uh could possibly imagine who hasn't
actually snuck out in red season of
mists in the sandman comics i want fans
to have watched those first 10 episodes
and to be
satisfied with all of the twists and the
turns
in the plot and to actually understand
what they've seen in ways that they
might not have seen up to that point
what are you going to do
something that i have never done before
something that will make god
absolutely
living
and bring
i think it's exciting because it feels
like it's going to be a huge change and
a huge shift and everything that we felt
we know
is going to ultimately change i haven't
seen it because i want to watch it in
the right way in a with a
i don't want to watch it on a sort of
link on a computer i want to have a
great sound and a big screen unlike me
i may be here a while
would you
mind
taking care of things
while i work
with pleasure sir
and i did wonder i thought
i wonder if it can go further will it be
a second season relaying groundwork in
case we are asked to make one how about
that i love sandman allen loves sandman
we we would love that to be a season two
i would love gilbert to just
pop up from the grass i hope i won't do
too much fighting of course it would be
a delight who knows what but they all
have him in mind you and your brother
are children of the endless
you have suffered enough
you may leave this place
goodbye rose
yeah i just hope to see you know rose
expanding and becoming a writer and
doing cool things i'm kind of sad about
the powers being gone now but like it
was very necessary you know the fate of
the world and stuff yeah you saved
humanity which is quite a job done thank
you very much
[Music]
you